Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Daniel Pink, who's the author of five
New York Times bestsellers, including the
latest The Power of Regret How Looking Forward
Moves US, I'm Sorry How Looking Backward Moves
US Forward.
Published last month.
Daniel, it's great to have you on today.
Speaker 4: Hey, thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So I read the book with great interest,
and the book both confirms some of the intuition
that we may have about regret and also and
also tells us that some of the intuitions
we have about regret are very, very wrong.
Maybe to start with, can you talk a little
bit about when it comes to the idea of it's
just better to live without regrets, which
is a very general principle that a lot of
people assume is just accurate?
Can you talk a little bit about what aspects
of that make sense and maybe where it falls
short?
Speaker 4: Well, it's I mean, it's a great
way to frame the question there.
When we when we look, we have this idea that
we should never look backward and that we
should if we feel a spear of regret, we should
essentially ignore that.
And that is actually colossally wrong headed
advice.
What the research tells us, what 50 years
of science tells us is that everybody has
regrets.
Regret is one of the most common emotions
that human beings have.
It is ubiquitous in the human condition.
It is actually part of our cognitive machinery.
And so to say that I don't look backward and
I don't experience regret runs against the
science, it's just simply not how human beings
operate.
So and the truth of the matter is that everybody,
you know, regret, regret makes us human.
Nearly everybody experiences regret.
I mean, literally, except for a very small
number of people with certain kinds of disorders.
Everybody experiences regret.
And if we use it right, it's actually useful
to us.
And this is the paradox of regret.
This is sort of the puzzle of regret, which
is that this emotion that makes us feel bad
is ubiquitous in the human experience.
So what why?
And the answer is because it helps us if we
deal with it right?
And we haven't been equipped to deal with
regret properly.
We've been taught in some ways to ignore it.
When that fails, we end up getting captured
by it.
And what we should be doing is confronting
our regrets.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you talk in the book about
and this doesn't seem unique to feelings of
regret.
But in the book you talk about how if the
thoughts of regret become intrusive, if they
become sort of bottomless, if they become
repetitive, that they end up having a sort
of counterproductive impact.
And it's not, it's not.
It's not good.
But that thinking about the regrets in particular
ways and using them is actually something
that that is a positive thing.
Can you talk a little bit about the difference
between that?
Because some people might say, Well, if I'm
not thinking about the regrets, then how can
I use them to my advantage?
Speaker 4: Well, so that's great.
Another great, another great question.
So it's really I think at a broader level,
we haven't been taught how to deal with negative
emotions.
I think our religious traditions actually
do a better job of equipping us to deal with
negative emotions.
I think secular society hasn't done a very
good job.
And so what happens is that some of us ignore
negative emotions.
We say, no, not real, got to be positive people.
People put our fingers in the years.
That's a bad idea.
But because we haven't been equipped to deal
with them when we do, when they intrude, as
you say, they can feel overwhelming.
And so we have to ask ourselves this question
about like, what are these negative feelings
for?
They're not for ignoring, they're not for
wallowing, they're for thinking about and
therefore thinking about, as you say, in a
particular way.
And there's a certain process by which we
can think about our emotions and arrest that
march toward rumination, arrest that march
toward getting sucked into the into the vortex.
And it's actually relatively simple.
And when we do that, the evidence is overwhelming
that that reckoning with our regrets leaning
into our regrets in some ways can help us
become better negotiators, better strategies,
better problem solvers, better parents and
find greater meaning in life.
Speaker 1: You know, it's interesting that
our interview is today and yesterday.
It just so happened that during these Supreme
Court confirmation hearings, particular sentences
that the nominee Judge Jackson had assigned
in the past were a topic of much discussion.
And she was asked numerous times Do you regret
the sentence you gave to this particular individual
who went on to re-offend or whatever the case
may be?
And one of the interesting things about that
framework is that it's sort of like a results
based regret where the time that that a decision
is made, you don't have the information as
to what subsequently happens.
And the question was based on what happened
after you decided.
Do you regret what you did?
And Daniel Kahneman has written about this
and in the context of it being sort of a cognitive
limitation that we sometimes experience?
Can you talk a little bit about results oriented
thoughts about regrets?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I mean, I don't want to legitimize those questions
about sentencing as as serious intellectual
inquiries
Speaker 1: agreed 100
Speaker 4: percent.
They were, they were.
Yeah, it was basically performative grandstanding
and dog whistles.
Absolutely.
I believe in leaving that.
Aside from leaving that aside for a moment,
and I know, I know that you agree with that.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, this is actually there are a couple
of ways at this.
One of them is as we were talking about before.
That's a way to arrest the march toward rumination.
That is what you need to evaluate is a decision
itself, not the not what happened subsequently,
because the decision itself is something you
had control over.
What happened subsequently is something you
don't have control over.
And so what I found in talking to people about
their regrets is they were actually much less
outcomes than I would have expected that they
were actually scrutinizing that, especially
when it came to a certain kinds of regrets.
They were much more willing to scrutinize
the decision itself and were less wedded to
the outcome.
Now all of us have that.
All of us have that cognitive glitch.
But but what's important to understand with
with regret is that when we evaluate our choices
and when we try to extract lessons from them,
we should be evaluating the context of the
decision, what we knew, what situation we
were in.
Who in some ways, who we were as a person
at that moment.
And because that's something we have control
over.
But the outcome itself, we don't always have
control over, although the outcome does, you
know, can give us clues.
Speaker 1: You in the book, you categorize
regrets into sort of certain buckets.
And in that context, you did this world regret
survey of 15000 people in more than 100 countries.
Can you talk about the categories of regret
that seem to be the most impactful for people
when they look back on their lives?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I mean, what I found in collecting regrets
from all over the world, as you mentioned,
we're now up to over 19000 regrets from over
from 109 countries.
It's unbelievable.
And what I found, which is, to my surprise,
is that over and over again, people had the
same core regrets.
They regretted the same things.
And these regrets are less about the domains
of people's lives.
They were less about, Oh, I have a career
regret.
I have an education regret.
I mean, superficially, that's what they were.
But deep down, there were four things that
people seem to regret the most, and I'll go
through them very quickly.
One of them, or what I call foundation regrets
foundation regrets are if only I'd done the
work.
And these are regrets about small decisions
people make about health, about finances,
about education early in life that accumulate
to, you know, sometimes very grave consequences
later on.
So things about especially things like not
saving enough money, spending too much money,
smoking those kinds of things.
Second one are boldness regrets, which are
if only I'd taken the chance.
These are regrets people have where they're
at a juncture in their life.
They can play it safe, they can take the chance
and they don't take the chance and they often
regret it.
And it's everything from traveling to speaking
up to asking somebody out on a date to starting
a business.
And what's interesting about those, David,
is that.
There were people who acted boldly and it
didn't work out.
And many of them said, I don't love that,
but I'm cool with that because I took the
chance, so that's a good example of what you
were talking about before people being, to
my surprise, being less outcomes than I would
have expected.
Third category, if only I'd done the right
thing.
These are people who again are at a juncture.
They can do the right thing.
They can do the wrong thing, to do the wrong
thing.
They regret it.
Bullying, marital infidelity.
Other kinds of cheating.
And finally, our connection regrets, which
are if only had reached out, which are about
relationships, not mostly romantic relationships,
just the full spectrum of relationships we
have in our lives that if they come apart
and we don't do anything about it, we end
up regretting it.
And and what's amazing to me in this research
is that is how universal these four regrets
were.
I mean, irrespective of, you know, of of nationality,
especially pretty much irrespective of gender
and to some extent, even irrespective of age.
Speaker 1: Are there certain cultures or countries
that just have a lower level of regret in
your estimation?
Speaker 4: I don't know.
That's an interesting question.
I tried to get at that.
I tried to get at that question in in a I
did another piece of that to the the world
regrets.
Everyone's a piece of qualitative research
that as I was essentially collecting stories,
I also did a piece of quantitative research,
which was a which essentially a giant opinion
poll of the American population.
The largest sampling of American attitudes
about regret ever conducted a pretty rigorous
quantitative survey.
And I tried to get at that.
A version of that question that way by asking,
say about, say, belief in God, does it believe
in God correlate with people's regrets?
D. Zero correlation of any kind.
I asked people, Do you gave people three choices?
Do you believe in God?
Which of these best describes your belief?
I believe in God.
I don't believe in God.
I'm not sure.
I believe in God and zero correlation of any
kind, with me, with anything.
I also asked people whether they believed
that in general, everything in life happened
for a reason.
And most people did it.
Most people also believe they have free will.
So, so, so other ways at that question about
belief systems seem to indicate there.
There wasn't much difference.
I mean, I'm not.
I'm hesitant to say that.
I'm very hesitant to say definitively.
My hunch right now is that that that that
belief systems didn't matter all that much.
And it could be because regret is so central
to our literally to our brain function.
That is, our brains don't have a nationality.
Our behavior can have a nationality because
as our brains acting in a context.
But ah, but the the lump of of of cells in
our head doesn't isn't, you know, an Indonesian
isn't an Indonesian brain or an American brain
or a Polish brain, it's just a brain.
Yeah, right is central.
Speaker 1: That makes sense.
I mean, at the same time, there are so many
cultural ideas and memes like, you know, FOMO
fear of missing out YOLO.
You only live ones that aren't the same across
all countries.
So it would be interesting whether, you know,
do Brazilians tend to have fewer regrets than
Danes vs. Americans or that type of thing?
And it sounds like we don't really have that
data, at least at this point.
Speaker 4: Not at all.
I mean, and in fact, if you're talking about
the number of regrets, I have no idea because
I because in my surveys, I asked people in
the quantitative survey, I asked people to
list one of their biggest regrets in the qualitative
survey.
Also, tell me about one big regret I didn't
ask.
You know, so, so it could.
There could be volume differences that people
in in in Slovenia have lots and lots of regrets,
and people in Brazil have only one or two.
And yet when you look at the top regrets,
the biggest regrets, there's commonality there.
Speaker 1: I the other thing that is interesting
is whether and you I think you touched on
this in the book a little bit, I think and
I've also read articles preparing for the
interview.
So now I'm not sure.
But one of the things is do more opportunities,
create an environment for having more regrets?
Whereas someone whose life felt like it provided
fewer opportunities reduces the amount of
regret that one might feel.
Speaker 4: Yes, although opportunity is also
an opportunity is a little bit paradoxical,
so let me give you let me give you a piece
of data on that from the quantitative survey
of the American Regrette Project, the big
public opinion poll.
What we found there was that people who had
high levels of formal education, that is,
they had degrees in advanced degrees, right?
Those people we know, which is which is a
minority of of of Americans, I think it's
something like 30 percent or so of Americans
have a college degree and an even smaller
percentage of that have a so-called advanced
degree.
And what we found there is that those folks,
the people with college degrees and advanced
degrees especially had more career regrets
than other people.
Which is weird because.
You know that.
But but it's so superficially weird, but it
goes to exactly to your point, which is that
the fact that they had more career opportunities
might have given them a larger universe of
career opportunities to regret right now.
That said, thwarted opportunity can also be
a source of regret.
So opportunity sort of lives at the core of
regret, but in a somewhat paradoxical way.
Huge numbers of opportunities can lead to
regret, but reduced opportunities.
Can also lead to regret.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to touch on in
terms of takeaways for one's own thinking
and actions and sort of life.
One principle that I got from the book maybe,
rightly, maybe wrongly, is in general, there
seems to be more regret for things not done
than for things done very, very broadly speaking.
Is that true and what other kind of general
principles that one can apply, do you think
are important?
Speaker 4: It is.
What you're saying is very true.
I mean, that think that that's a claim that
I can make without with very little hesitation
based on the existing research and based on
my own research and the quantitative survey,
that was a very, very clear finding, particularly
when it comes to age when we're younger, we
tend to have equal regrets of of of action,
things I did and inaction what I didn't do
as we age.
Overwhelmingly, it's regrets of inaction.
And I think that the takeaway there is that
in general in life, we should have a slight
bias for action that that in some ways we're
generally over indexed on risk and we're over
indexed on feelings of awkwardness.
So we think that asking somebody out on a
date has a high level of risk when it actually
doesn't.
We think that reaching out to a friend who's
drifted apart, it has high levels of awkwardness,
but it really doesn't.
We think this is a little bit closer to the
line.
But but we sometimes overindex on how much
risk it is to start a business.
And and so I think that a takeaway is that
we should have a in general in life a bias
for action because action is also a way that
it's also a way that we learn things.
So I think sometimes we plan too much and
act too little, which we feel like in order
to act, we have to plan out everything when
in fact, acting itself is a form of planning
and understanding.
So I think that's one big takeaway.
The other big takeaway is, I think in terms
of how we reckon with our regrets is that
we should recognize that when we feel regret
it is utterly human and that when we do that,
we should treat ourselves with kindness rather
than contempt.
Recognize that it's part of the human condition.
We should talk about our regrets and use language
to make sense of our regrets, and we should
explicitly stop and try to extract a lesson
from those regrets.
So if we do that, if we say, you know, this
is this is this is what I regret.
It's totally normal.
I'm going to treat myself with kindness.
Let me try to make sense of it.
Let me draw a lesson from it and let me apply
that lesson next time.
Then it's an incredibly productive and even
transformative emotion.
Speaker 1: The book is the power of Regret
How Looking Backward Moves US Forward.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Daniel Pink.
Really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me.
It was a pleasure.